good morning
well here's to me we the most more say
suggestions annoyances and other things
have come from one of the films that are
made about in while reverse as I think I
the thing is we get so passionate about
our heart why over the art that we we
won't have anything said against there
because it's one we've chosen therefore
that puts a seal of approval early it's
obvious II got to be the best one most
of us wouldn't have done research to
find out what we need and it's very
strange how I could have it feels so
many people's expectations it's almost
like take the boxes what my kiddo would
do for you and there's not many boxes
left on ticked I've been teaching there
a long time and I've got students have
been following me for well 40 years and
yet they still don't want to do
everything that you need to do to say
that your true Aikido to following our
senses path in one of the early films I
had a comment come back from a lady
saying could I talk more about why yoga
is important in my opinion to Aikido
there's a there's a film of our senses
sittin on rooftop of a building and it
as he sets their smile here I think
talking his he's got one leg stretch the
other one Bend and he's rotating his
ankle so most I could okay with no this
is what we consider a warm-up exercise
well in fact it's a yoga exercise lot of
the yoga that most sensi I see him doing
isn't Aikido it's fundamentally to keep
his body flexible and fit so he can do
Aikido so when I see my own students
been training for about forty years and
yet still avoiding doing any form of
looking after their body they might use
their body drinking too much eating too
much not doing yoga or any form of
flexibility cardiovascular they think
that Aikido will give them everything
they need how sad it is for me to watch
them they could friends as well now
after all these years that they don't
become students they become friends and
yet it's almost like why don't we ever
feel that we can talk to our friends
personally you have taken to one side
isn't it time you really got down to
doing some stretching I I question my
own thoughts on this is it because I
think well the age they are now is not
going to benefit
don't improve don't like you know
they're saying their ways
they should have started when they were
younger
no you you you're never too old because
I'm bodies made up of ligaments tendons
fashio muscle we have to maintain it if
we eat bad food then eat good food
sometimes try to balance their health
don't tell yourself I know not by eat
bad food and I should look after myself
better who are you talking to you know
there's only one over you you might
think that you're talking one Tony to
the other Tony of Times beating yourself
up immensely about what you should do
but what you don't I sense his Aikido
his bits very little of his as far as
the the martial parlor the bird owned
the fighting techniques I don't know him
well enough to say if he actually
created any of them all I know is a
tournament from Mongolia China Japan and
he took them from lots of different
martial arts I know for much of Tai Chi
master that some of the techniques such
as Akio Carnegie
these were taken from John the Chinese
and they were only talked to their
masters they won't talk to the everyday
practitioners in Chinese martial arts
there was what they considered secret
techniques I don't know what makes them
secret I'm not learning enough to read
the depths of understand
I'd love to show you this very nice
sculptured workings that makeup won't be
considered as an old-fashioned watch now
these at one stage were something that
worked bringing this state they cannot
work anymore but never will again if
your training Aikido Alinea martial art
do you want to become like the watch
frozen in time
every piece there that we know that some
parts of that watch didn't come from
Japan possibly Switzerland says it's got
subject goodnight for watches there
might be some parts of Chinese in there
we need to look alike in my opinion as a
whole we take the martial side and we
can learn the techniques but shouldn't
we be looking at what our body must do
if you can't easily do a squat at any
age 1718 older if you live to be older I
see young people in their twenties who
can't do a squat from a standing
position and yet if he was an Indian
waiting for a bus you would all be
squatting your backside almost touching
the ground and you'd be having
conversation then you'd think nothing of
it
the home of your or I always think as
so why does aikido need yoga as either
the questions asked you needed to find
many many techniques I sense he
performed because without but having a
flexible body you need a flexible mind
but they used to compare your weaknesses
in your strengths to compare what you
should be doing and what you are doing
but when it comes to the body in these
exercise then is cardiovascular if you
do the flying style of like you know
that would give you the cardiovascular
if you do the in Wileman style you won't
be doing so much cardiovascular it's not
fast and flowing it's very demanding s
business fastest flap and flying in my
experience so this is why whether you
like or not please consider what you can
start doing what stretches can you do
you don't have to touch your toes or put
the flats of your hands on the floor
when you bend over to be good at Yoga
you can stretch the backs of your legs
you can try standing on your toes have a
wall next to your chair try the tree
pose get better balance please start by
looking at yoga and in time Yoga will
look at you and you will find that
you're able to do more Aikido techniques
more easily it's never too late only you
can decide when the time comes and by we
keep hearing from my closest friend
students I know I should do it and I
must do it but I don't like doing it I
don't like that given the time to
stretch in that I love doing the class
but I don't like the times you made me
do the yoga my body just doesn't like
doing it it hurts me I find it difficult
the life is difficult and you've only
got one life you've only got one body
make the most of it I tried to do yoga
as much as I can before I start my day I
don't always have told him but if you
done one stretch or one yoga exercise
for a few days then have a break and
then try another one there's plenty of
films on YouTube there's plenty of books
you can do at home if you don't want to
do a class I encourage you all please
start yoga I sense he done it he done it
for a reason if you want to do like you
know you need to start collecting like
the watch you need to start collecting
the parts that our sensor used to make
use a heart so great and we'll talk in
the future about the techniques and
other things that I think you need to
enhance your ru Aikido sorry please
subscribe if you're enjoying these
because I hope to keep continue them if
their subscriptions go up then I know
more people are enjoying them and likes
or not likes with your comments below
are always welcome
it's your chance to say when you think
thank you